bootle cat podcast man you already know
go check out the full interview with
Cassidy out right now but it's time we
just get to it man let's get to These
Bars man
[Music]
goat gang Philly [__] you know how we
carry it look if I snitch they would
have shot me in the face but the plug
respect me I could directly hit poppy on
the waist I was young I had to run but
what got me in the races I'm hot as [__]
Aki stop popping [__] before I take a
hockey stick and play hockey with your
face I'm original what you [__] do is
copying and Pace I'm not sloppy I'm in
shape you decide to try angles on me the
next step is to catch wreck tangle Homie
Get mango homie a friend jump in I'll
strangle homie then beat both of you
[__] up I don't give a [__] the 40 on
my hip and the stick in the truck big as
[__] try to rob me I won't give it up I
hit them up I did it up but live it up
I'll be losing track imma Live It Up
move forward I'm never moving back
usually catch shoes in the ball or get
they booty smack I choose the rap give
me my credit like when the movie rap I
use a strap I find out use a rat you get
clapped in all your friend dead little
Uzi track facts don't make me spin the
block last op that I shot in the box and
won't get to shoot me back goofy cats
need to relax and get off the internet
if Tom money homie you only got one
minute left you got the guap and cop the
watch spend your check how you got the
guap but did not stop at the dentist yet
your peace dripping Diamond shining on
each wrist but you never got your teeth
fixed I ain't finished yet I've been the
threat and I ain't in the wreck if I
send a threat a headshot with a old dog
you saw him in this [__] you've been to
bed against the goat you won't win the
bet I've been a threat and I'm still him
pin ain't diminished [__] I've been up
and been in debt I've been the best if
it's drama imma pull up like I'm doing
tender set and for the record my record
ain't got a blemish [__] yo I'm
proactively proven it's no match for me
I thought my bro a QP he throw a rat
back to me Cassidy independent no
billionaires is backing me I'm in the
big body bins the rims Factory these
cats actually sweeter than strawberry
daiquiri they can't rap with me I'm the
vote bro a lot of guys in all your top
five I ghost wrote for you should play
less and get coach Mall say less when
dudes leave interrogation rooms they
throw sore
longscape [__] some hope sure but now
[__] more broke watching you vote for
I turned to have brick to 36 if the coke
pure since loud legal while people
opening smoke stores and you ain't got
to question why my weapon's so long I'm
a legend I've been stepping so long all
of my toes saw is brochure you want to
go to war I got a brochure that's a
little mag I mean that's a little
magazine I shoot rounds and move pounds
of the gasoline but me facing time hard
to see like I cracked my screen
bars
Jesus
Cassidy yeah hey I know you just watched
a new freestyle guess what we're
dropping them every week sometimes more
than once a week Jesus we've been
dropping a lot lately uh shout out to
LRG don't forget go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this for
this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-d-g.com promo code bootleg and save
30 off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week